for Commodities it seems that All That Glitters Is
Gold amid recent turmoil in the financial system
and concerns over the health of the global economy
gold has remained stable here's why the precious
metal is continuing to shine investors piled into
gold in March the price is currently hovering at
just under two thousand dollars an ounce and it
has risen 8.4 this year the recent rise comes
after the collapse of Silicon Valley Bank and
Signature Bank in the US and the Takeover of
Swiss Bank Credit Suisse by its rival UBS a late
March sell-off in Germany's Deutsche Bank has also
ramped up concerns about the financial system
but yet gold has sparkled through the chaos in
investors value gold for its stability during
uncertain times and often look to the precious
metal as an alternative to the traditional banking
system here's one example of its recent appeal in
the week following the svb collapse net inflows
into gold exchange traded funds stood at roughly
14 tons that's over 1 billion dollars worth for a
couple of months before the collapse investors had
been pulling money out of funds in March gold
benefited from expectations That central banks
would reduce the speed of interest rate hikes
in order to cut pressure on the financial system
over the last year the Federal Reserve has raised
interest rates in a bid to tame inflation these
hikes made goal less attractive for investors
because unlike other Investments the metal does
not pay interest in March Fed chair Jerome Powell
announced yet another rate rise but he hinted that
it could be the last one for now leading to
a jump in gold prices we no longer state that
we anticipate that ongoing rate increases will be
appropriate to coil inflation gold is also getting
a boost from a decline in the dollar a weaker
dollar lifts the price of Commodities that are
backed by the US currency one of which is gold to
compare gold had a more lackluster year in 2022
it was briefly trading at about two thousand
dollars an ounce following Russia's invasion of
Ukraine however as the FED began lifting its rates
to curb inflation the dollar soared to a 20-year
High which led to a slight climb down in gold
prices but the US dollar has since retreated from
its 2022 Peak which has enabled gold prices to
bounce back towards the end of March gold prices
Rose towards its record level before dropping down
slightly that's as rescue measures for struggling
Banks helped ease contagion fears however
analysts expect gold to remain resilient it
has been performing strongly remaining above 1500
an ounce for the last three years according to
the world gold Council analysts at Fitch Solutions
believe that mounting Global Financial instability
is likely to keep on driving up gold prices
solidifying's reputation as a safe haven asset